各位同学大家好
今天已经进入第六堂课了
然后呢
今天这堂课呢
我们要分享的是主副歌结构与韵脚使用之变化
嗯听起来是正规军哦
要打仗咯
真枪实弹哦
今天的课程比较特别会有一些辅助的教材
然后呢这些辅助的教材多数会在屏幕上显示好
我们首先先介绍一个叫趋势
什么叫趋势呢
曲式某种程度有点像宋词的词牌名
还是文字排列的段落的格式
你填词的时候
如果人家要求你先有词
那你要先懂曲式就非常重要了
通常音乐圈大多数的状态下是先有曲再有词
所以作词也叫填词
把文字填进音乐的格式里面
但是某些时候作曲的人
他需要有个完整可以入月的格式
就是先有词帮助他有画面
这个状况也是有的
所以各位同学一定要先认识什么叫曲式
流行音乐的曲式
它有一个基本的格式
这个格式是古典音乐没有的
所以有时候你听莫扎特跟贝多芬的音乐
你听不到主副歌的区别
他是比较自由的
它不会局限于一个重复的节奏
但是因为流行音乐很重要
是生活的调剂
他是听觉上的一个疗愈的一种声音
所以它必须有重复的格式
让你去记住那些旋律
这很重要的
所以曲式对流行音乐来讲很重要
但是古典音乐你是听不出它有明显的趋势
它也不需要
这是古典乐跟流行音乐一个作曲上很大的区隔
好接下来我们看屏幕上的曲式
首先我有四个主要的曲式
最常见的就是两大段
A one a two b one b two
那假设人家要求你先有取的话
记得这个是最标准的模式
就是有四大段
那通常一大段都是八小节
所以你就记住喽
就是a one a two是主歌
所有的主歌待会会介绍什么叫主歌
什么叫副歌
然后b one b two是所谓的副歌
副歌通常都是记忆点的所在
记住旋律的地方
那大家填词的时候
记得你去填这样子的格式的时候呢
通常你就是比较有记忆点的地方
需要放在副歌的第一行
等一下会介绍好
接下来看第二个趋势
第一个趋势是a one a two所有的主歌
然后主歌进入副歌前会有个倒歌呃
引导的岛
而这个倒戈通常也是八小节
有时候会有四小节
所以这个曲式是稍微丰富了一点
就是a one1two b c one c two
第三种是很很简单
他就是主歌完就副歌了
就a b a b b one b two
因为副歌通常要重复唱
所以呢它会有两段b one b two
最后一种是现在有一些呃作曲者
他会把副歌直接拉上来
有时候你听诶
怎么一下子就有记忆点了
他就把副歌拿来当前面的段落
它就是me就直接开始副歌了
然后再来A主歌
再来me one me two副歌
这是主要的四个趋势的一个段落
好的曲式分享完之后
我们接下来讲押韵的方法
同学们记得押韵的方法其实是很变化的
是很活泼的
你不需要整首歌从头押同一个韵脚
其实不需要
但是有些人习惯了啦
那这个可能就是呃一种个人的创作风格
但是最好是要有变化
所以变化是说你可以D大段主歌a one一个韵脚
然后第二大段的a two也是换韵脚
可以这样子的
然后副歌再换另外一个韵脚
另外一种韵脚就是说在段落里面变化
什么叫在段落里面变化
通常八小节的一个副歌
中文呈现的话是四行
那这四行你可以怎么押韵呢
你可以押124运
第三行不押韵没有关系
另外你可以全押嘛
1234都押同个韵脚
记得很多变化
那最不好的方式是四行来讲
你可能134押韵
二不押这个听觉上是不对的
因为音乐行进间的段落
它可能四小节的段落
所以呢你押韵的时候一定要一二压同个韵脚
三四押一个韵脚
或者是1234押个同个韵脚
然后另外一个变化就是说你可以主歌押个韵脚
副歌换一个韵脚
这样会比较活泼
另外一个方式是你可以压二四韵哦
这是很特别的哦
但是241定要同个韵脚
这样听觉上的那个聆听度
它才是一致的画面
这是听觉上的画面感
就是你可以一很很自由的写
然后二有韵脚
然后三很自由的写
四有韵脚
因为听觉上它的结束是在二跟四
所以这是另外一种小变化
这是除了趋势之外
韵脚押韵的一个段落的方法
其实韵脚比较重要
应该是副歌
副歌是一首歌的灵魂
而且是听觉记忆最强的地方
但有时候主歌有些民谣风的主歌
他不太注重韵脚
其实也没有太大的问题
那主要是focus记忆点的副歌
尽量建议还是要韵脚
因为它毕竟是歌词
而不是形式
那歌词的跟音乐结合的文字
最好有个听觉的连接度跟记忆
一点
接下来等下我们要分享的这个韵脚表
韵脚表很特别
它应该是武林秘籍哦
武林秘籍哦
这个没有公开过的哦
然后这个现代流行音乐的韵脚
跟以前古诗词的平仄是不一样的
古代的平仄是什么
平平仄仄仄平平
它是整段句去讲究
但是我们现在流行音乐只注重最后一个音而已
所以基本上我们不太用得到凭证的
原因是因为以前的评测是诊断句
平平仄仄仄平平
他要遵守一个创作的规范
所以我就说以前古诗词不是那么好写
以前古诗词的平仄早期是平上去入
后来入声消失了
就把平变成阴平阳平
那这样子介绍可能大家还是比较没有概念
你就把它想象成四声
譬如说方方房仿放那方防就是平声
然后仿放是这方仿仿放那这两个音是平仄
所以古诗词的平仄是这样子来的
但这个我们用不到
所以这个先先搁着
让大家了解就好了
要进入武林秘籍韵脚表之前
先给大家看一本书
这个叫做新华字典
这个基本上就是工具书的了
应该是每个人家里面都有
那之所以给大家看这本
是
因为我的韵脚表
是以我习惯用的注音符号去分类
但是呢新华字典里面有注音符号
跟汉语拼音的一个对照表
所以同学们要聚精会神哦
要进入武林秘籍的阶段
各位同学看到屏幕上的这个韵脚表的毛
这个韵脚表呢大家看一下
我不是用韵母或声母去给它分类的
我是用听觉韵
只是我觉得这两个音发音是相近的
因为以流行音乐来讲
听觉韵是比较重要的
而且会省了很多麻烦
像这个韵脚表
它里面有三个区块
一个是声母
一个是介音
第二个是韵母
那其实韵母
你可以把它理解成英文音标里面的母音
多数的状况下我们用到韵脚是母音
也就是韵母
接下来介绍说分了哪几个大类
第一个是zh xz z xx这个听觉上是同韵脚
所以千千万万不要单独归类
否则你押韵创作的时候会很辛苦
他怎么的区分呢
就是说心事城市样子全部把它归类为同个韵脚
通常作词的人都都知道
比如你的样子是我怀念的心思
在某个陌生的城市如何回去
往事有没有滋滋滋
这是一个韵脚
听觉韵记得
所以呢这几个都把它归类为同一个韵脚
另外是RR是独立的
譬如说可能说话
然后玫瑰花想家脸颊
这是阿韵
像翁韵的话
可能像霓虹面容
天空有没有
他的嘴型几乎是一致的
这样子的韵脚独立性很强
这个是单独运
再来一个是O跟OO跟窝
他听觉上是同韵脚
比如说可能回首回头难过轮廓
你有没有注意到
我说的一直强调听觉韵听起来是一样
然后再来是A跟Y心碎憔悴
风雪蝴蝶听起来是一样
虽然它的韵母不一样哦
也就是所谓的母音不一样哦
但是记得我的要求是听觉韵听起来一样
就把它当做同个韵脚使用
这样子你押韵的时候变化比较多
然后选项比较好
比较灵活
再来就是1V回忆
泪滴雏菊结局UUUU听起来是一样的
所以我把YU当做同个韵脚使用
再来是UU乌态是独立的
可能孤独幸福道路征服乌运
但是爱爱也是独立的
像明白坦白分开
这是独立的一个韵脚
还有一个独立的韵脚是A
就说坎坷黄河这个E这是一个独立的韵脚
还有an跟ANAN的话是沮丧脸庞
安日河岸沙滩听起来是一样
虽然它是不同的韵母
也就是所谓的母音
记得我要求是听觉韵
这个是可以合并使用的
N也是独立韵
我举首歌好了
像烟花易冷雨纷纷
旧故里草木深
我听闻你始终一个人
烟花易冷
人事易分
明白还是同个韵脚
独立韵再来凹
OALWAYS是独立韵脚
微笑你好
海角饮料
这是一个独立的韵脚
然后最后是饮跟音听觉上一样
我就把它放在一起
使用申隐的音
风景的景
那这个是声音的音
用印的印
你几乎分不出来
对不对
所以说这个一定是一起使用同个韵脚
那你这样子去搭配的时候
这样子的韵脚就很活泼
很自由
而且记住我刚刚有提醒
段落的韵脚不需要一韵到底
你可以主歌一个韵脚
副歌一个韵脚
你可以光副歌的四个段落里面
也就是四行中文
你都可以两个韵脚
这是可以自
有搭配的
接下来要解答一个大家长久以来的困惑
什么叫主歌
什么叫副歌
有时候你就觉得很奇怪
这个流行音乐这个段落明明就是最主要好听的
记忆点最深的
为什么他只反而叫副歌
正负的负好像不叫不重要
叫负嘛
明明就是最重要的段落
听觉上是最记忆点最深的地方居然叫副歌
这是为什么
它是翻译的问题
副歌的英文叫cos
它的原意是合唱团齐声一起唱歌的意思
所以那个副是重复的复
让听众恍然大悟了
因为副歌是流行音乐的记忆点
它的旋律是重复重复重复
但是呢翻译出了问题
就是把重复的负写成正负的负
所以呢从此以后我们的副歌就变成正负的负
而不是重复的负了
然后主歌叫verse
主歌的原意是诗句诗篇
这个是回归到呃西方早期在教堂唱圣歌的时候
他们通常会有一个人起音
单独一个
然后唱了一段之后
再有一群人一起合唱
唱所有的福音歌
宗教歌曲
它的结构是这样子的
但引进我们这边东方的时候
我们翻译出了问题
所以呢各位同学
我们是歌词创作班
千万不要有一天人家问你说诶
副歌为什么叫副歌啊
你回答不出来
那就好笑
记得它原意是英文的重复的复
之所以会出现这样子的错误
你只能说西方拥有现代流行音乐的话语权
这个没有办法
你仔细想想看哦
我们所有的音乐类别
从节奏蓝调灵魂乐
爵士嘻哈电音摇滚
雷鬼重金属
哪一个适合我们东方原有的或我们发明的曲风
没有当话语权掌握在他们手上的时候
当初引进的那些术语已经发生错误之后
大家已经习惯了
也没有人想要去更改
所以变成大家都觉得说
明明副歌就是记忆点感情最催泪的地方
每次想要哼哼唱唱
疗愈自己的心情的时候
你记住的都是副歌的音
唱的都是副歌的句子
可他明明是最好最精彩的段
那为什么是正负的负哦
原来他是重复的负